this is a production of Cornell
University it's on okay I won't use my
microphone yes I've talked about the
broccoli project you're quite a number
of times over the years but I realize in
this venue I haven't talked about my
cover crop work even though I talk about
it nearly every week some audience
during the fall and early but this would
be a good chance and especially as it
impinges on the work that a lot of you
are doing and sort of reinforces the
connections that we have around some of
these questions of production and
biology and so my big goal with the
cover crop work is to make vegetable
production more environmentally and
economically sustainable that's kind of
the big picture and you'll find that
everything probably fits into that big
picture and there will be a lot of
smaller threads so most of the work in
cover crops when I started was done for
field crops and field crops are very
very constrained they get planted in the
spring as soon as you can get in the
ground they get harvested when the
weather starts to fall and that doesn't
make for a very exciting cover crop
scenario vegetables are really different
and some of the things that really play
into how you think about putting cover
crops into a vegetable production are
one thing is that it's very high revenue
on the plus side for somebody who's
trying to change practices is that if
it's if what you're doing is useful it's
we're spending money on so people are
more likely to adopt it on the other
hand it messes things up it can cause
growers growers a lot of money and it
also in some of the decision making
getting the crop off the field is even
more important because you can easily
have a situation that we have a lot
field is too wet crop is ripe what do
you do well if you have ten thousand
dollars worth of crop on land that cost
five thousand dollars an acre what's
your call you're going to go in there
and write it up no doubt about it
terrible for soil health in a moment but
that's going to be the decision so you
end up with people doing things for
short-term benefits that are bad for the
long-term vegetables compared to other
crops produce very little organic matter
so there's a need to supplement that
with other things in the cropping system
tillage is traditionally very intense
with vegetables compared to most other
crops certainly compared to fruits even
even better bigger contrast than with
field crops and I'll talk about the
issues with village as we get into it at
the very high fertility setting it
particularly when you're harvesting
before seed maturity if the crop is
still green and growing it wants a high
nitrogen environment and so you're
harvesting when there's high nitrogen
you're leaving a high nitrogen residue
the nitrogen management becomes quite
different from a field crop that you're
harvesting your crops maturity when if
you've done it right you've run the soil
nitrogen down to zero and there are very
diverse rotations vegetable crop
producer generally is trying to harvest
for as much of the season as possible so
that you get paid for as much of the
season as possible
here we can grow tomatoes great and
deliver all kinds of tomatoes the second
week in September but if that's all you
guys you have no market so you have
harvest all season well for cover crops
that provides a lot of different
opportunities and it also creates the
need for a lot of different solutions
give examples of some of those but
should say here my my motivation for
really getting into the cover crops in a
big way I've been playing around with it
before was Carol McNeil so she retired a
couple of years ago from Cooperative
Extension but she was really key player
in the soil health program and really
worked very hard at getting cover crop
adoption and especially important to me
identifying very precisely what the
needs of the growers were the where
where
I in doing research in this area provide
more information and so finding that
highest unaddressed grower needs me she
was a really good partner in making sure
I was doing something useful and
understanding how to develop a
curriculum of information that's useful
to the Extension educator so it's not
research reports it's not a little fact
journal back there it's here's a set of
ideas a set of practices that you can
actually learn and use and so that was
really important to my development to
extension and partnering with the soil
health team you'll see that a lot of
this is structured around the soil
health practices another kind of
introductory notion does something about
our geography and where my partnerships
have been in doing this work so the blue
and green on here is those are alpha
salsas are the really high quality
highly productive soils and you see they
run across the Ontario plain over into
Michigan quite a bit so Geneva and
Lansing are really very similar in many
regards I quite a bit of work with
Michigan State but we've got that band
and so having Geneva right
in the middle of that spot makes it
convenient not only because our our land
is just like the farmers land but the
farmers are right there to work with but
I'd say my work is intended to influence
two colorful areas on this map and yeah
so some some thought these can be sort
of takeaways if you want some practice
so one of the things I tried to focus on
is making sure that the cover crop is
managed is matched to the management
goal that the growers really need to
have something they are trying to
accomplish that is difficult to do with
the tool the other tools that they have
so bringing in a cover crop to do
biologically what they're having trouble
doing with their other set of tools
different cover crops do different
things different times of the season so
finding the right one and identifying
exactly what the management goal is
sometimes takes some shifts in thinking
another one it's really important to
reduce tillage if you want the cover
crops to do much good and that's
something that's become more and more
clear to me over the past 10 years and
I'll show you some examples of that
so coupling with the reduced tillage and
vegetable program so on it's not air
Brian Brian they're doing really really
important work and so time with two
ideas in those two programs together is
important and with the cover crops
timing is really critical and usually
growers think about cover crops oh I'll
get it in when I get around to it and
that doesn't work any better for cover
crops and it does brother I'm sensitive
let's all start off with soil health
because that's been a real organizing
principle of this and a place where you
really have an opportunity to have
considerable improvement that's one of
the cynical statements about the soil
health report is that you get a
prescription for what to do and
typically it's reduced tillage and use
more cover crops so some some people why
do I need to test if that's what it's
going to tell me but it tells you which
things do what's the specific management
goal is so here's the soil health test
report here's a eight indicators for
physical ones and for biological ones
that are typically coming out of the
report and these can be addressed with
reduced tillage and cover crops in
different ways and with cover crops it's
really different cover crops for each of
those indicators and they're related to
one another and I'm not going to dwell
on this one in fact I'm just going to
focus on the aggregate stability one for
today squeeze everything in so aggregate
stability is the soils aggregation and
kind of give you a picture of what that
can look like so the bad crumb here is
what ground looks like if you tell it a
lot don't put in enough organic matter
and
when it's wet it falls apart so there
are no crumbs in it there are no air
spaces in it if you try to break that
apart it will break into big clods and
it'll break into the individual mineral
particles so that's unfortunately taken
out of a vegetable field and this is
good crumb this is soil that was taken
next to a vegetable field it hasn't been
tilled it was in the hedgerow so it
looked like that but you can see those
crumbs they work like little ball
bearings so you can break up the soil
easily it tells fairly easily these
stick together because they're very well
glued together that's what we want
that's provides a lot more air spaces
for the roots to grow for respiration
and for the soil biology to work and
this is a picture of where those
aggregates come from so in this case
we're working with buckwheat which was
the first cover crop I chose to work
with because we'd been doing buckwheat
rain stuff and so this is the outside of
the root these are the root hairs you
see going out and you see there's all
kinds of the mineral particles in the
soil all kinds of different sizes right
that's important they're stuck together
to different extents now the cool thing
about this picture is that it's the soil
sheath so what Margaret did to get this
picture where she pulls the the wound
really out of the soil and then she
washed it with water and this is what's
stuck to the root this doesn't come off
and what's happened is the roof has
pushed so water is coming out of the
roots kind of make that point with a
bunch of mucopolysaccharides produced by
the root surface pushed out here and
that glues is stuff together and that's
about as far as the the water could get
well pushes a bunch of other things out
there so this is food for all the
biology of the rhizosphere and one of
the cool things about Cornell is that
there are at least a dozen labs working
very hard on what's going on in there
who's there what are they doing what do
they like how can we do good
we have them do good things for us so
there's tremendous activity right here
about what's going on in this picture I
find very exciting it's going to lead to
answers I want to know so the first set
of experiments I'm going to talk about
we're trying to figure out which cover
crop would be most helpful for improving
soil health and aggregate stability in
particular which we're going to talk
about here so there's a bunch of cover
crops available they have fine root
systems coarse root systems they grow at
different times of year they secrete
different things so in terms of just
practical we want to move our aggregate
stability up what should we use we
looked at two main windows one is after
an early vegetable crop so that we'd be
planting around the 20th of July and
then for a midseason cover crop planting
around the 20th of August and we didn't
worry about later than that because
these were the two time frames that were
of most interest and so we put this
experiment in where we had the same
cover crop for for off seasons in a row
and we had different vegetables in each
of the years so after four years how
much change were we able to produce we
knew that it was unlikely we'd see
anything in one year to rent for for
planting the same crop four times in a
row didn't want to push it any further
than that was enough and then looked at
various measures of soil health and crop
performance and just to orient you a
little bit this is from the soil health
handbook
what's good bad and terrible so with wet
aggregate stability on a medium soil is
the dotted line so if you're if you want
green good you want an aggregate
stability of at least about so in the
30s here but the two fields I was using
we're down here
they're about eighteen and twenty there
are definitely in the red zone so they
were in bad shape one worse than the
others
so the question is can we put them up
push them out of the really bad zone at
least into the not so terrible zone
we're asking a lot of the cover crop at
this point but also a fairly common
situation so this is with the early
summer cover crops so the two colored
bars or the two different fields and the
first one is with where we had bare
ground in the offseason so just open
fallow so these are the aggregate
stability values after four years with
the basically current practice and then
use yellow mustard buckwheat Sudan grass
annual rye grass and these are sort of
an order of how big the root system is
so thinking that a bigger root system
might have a bigger effect and what we
find is that there's some hints but
nothing is really coming out as
statistically significant and if you're
getting an improvement of one percent a
year to get up to 40 is going to be a
long haul so it's even even if it's
moving it's not moving very fast with
these early summer ones say these three
are only in the ground for about two and
a half months the early summer is nice
because you get the long days and warm
temperatures of July and August to work
with annual ryegrass actually survives
into the spring so it's fortunate longer
but not moving this measurement these
are the late summer cover crops so again
the bare ground first so that's the
control but here we get to use more
we've got radish yellow mustard and
turnip so those are all crews first
they're all dying sometime during the
winter brian treated Kaylee our rains
and finally annual ryegrass is in turf
type so it's a finer sod root system
there
and the rhyme one kind of looks tempting
it's a very commonly used one but even
with that one and I'm a little wary of
it because triticale is almost exactly
the same thing and so if we had
something that was going to be
consistent I would want to see triticale
up so what we're seeing in this highly
tilled system is that even cover
cropping very aggressively for four
years it's really hard to move the
needle and if you're planning on doing a
master's degree project and starting
from scratch this may not be the type of
experiment you want to do so what's the
deal with the tillage here so we were
tilling to plant the crop and we're
tilling to incorporate the residue of
the crop and prepare the ground for the
cover crop so that's quite a bit of
tillage in a year so this is a paper
that is about to come out from a
colleague and a see so they're working
on a similar soil and there they've done
wheat and betch as their offseason cover
crops and when they're and so this
measures the infiltration rate of water
which is pretty closely related to the
aggregate stability so they moved it
from an inch and a half with the fallow
up to a little over two inches with the
to cover a little bit since rains in
that range are really potentially
problematic that matters but look what
happens when you stopped tilling much
bigger increase in the water
infiltration and what did the cover
crops do when you stopped tilling much
bigger impact having five inches of
infiltration would be amazing there's a
lot of water that just goes into the
ground doesn't run off but the thing is
this is after 34 years
so that's a long time presumably
something happened before 34 years but
we know that by 34 years something has
happened and Harold Vanessa's group has
a trial similar to this going on up in
Aurora and I think they're five years
into it or so and it's it's starting to
get interesting looking but there it's
not going to pull away like this for a
few more years by the looks of it so
what can we do to reduce tillage and
vegetables like we're going to take
advantage of this effect how should we
be thinking of this instead of adding
cover crops to overcome the tillage
saying that's probably not the way it
works it's we have to use cover crops to
avoid the need for tillage and so
thinking about what's going on
structurally in the soil so this is our
tilled soil and it's reconsolidated so
we fluff it up the plant stuff but it
has very little aggregate stability and
structural properties so it
reconsolidate slike that after by the
end of the season it's compacted again
so we keep fluffing it up growing stuff
and having it fall together so that's
that's why it's hard to make progress
what is what does no-till end up looking
like just having a picture in your head
of what reducing tillage looks like and
this is one that I dug up so here we're
starting to get worm holes there's some
root pulls coming through there the
worms can go even where there's been a
bigger root so those things are
happening when the soil is wetter than
it is in this picture but you can see
that it's starting to develop a
structure where it can support weight it
can support your equipment but it's
still perforated and so the the source
of the air spaces is really different
than what you get when you do tillage so
this is what we're trying to drive for
so getting those whoop holes in there is
really important and then leaving it
alone and over a long period of time ten
to thirty four years is when you're
starting to get so much perforation that
it actually starts to behave the way you
want it to and the
choosing a cover crop to work with this
or to do that sort of thing is important
here's an example of different root
systems this is millet and sorghum Sudan
grass if you look at the seedlings when
they're coming up you can't tell the
difference you look really alike but you
look at those root systems if you want
to find root system with a lot of
surface area
millets your cover crop but if you want
really strong thick roots that can punch
through a compacted soil sorghum Sudan
grass as the thick roots that can do
that so the choice is really important
even though they know they're right next
to each other in the seed catalog and
they look alike it's easy to say well
they're out of this again grass I'll get
the miller well you've got to match the
cover crop with the purpose that you
have and I can't do this talk without
showing the aptly-named tillage radish
so if you're paid any attention
whatsoever to cover crops in this neck
of the woods for the last five years you
will have heard a lot about village
riders it's all the rage I've got a
neighbor farmer who plants about 1,500
acres of it each year he's still cropper
but it's working for him and so what
everybody notices is wow it's a big old
daikon radish that makes it below 2 inch
hole in the ground which is nice but
it's not actually that deep this really
is where the dirt stops that's really
the soil level so it's only going down a
couple of inches so the action really is
there little tap roots and they have
strong gravitropism going to keep trying
to grow straight down I should have
rotated the picture to talk about
gravitropism but there you go you're
looking from above so they're a couple
of millimeters wide but a couple of
millimeters wide to punch a hole that's
big enough to get the worms through it's
big enough to get the beetles through
the spring tails all the Meisel fauna
they can move around in the different
parts of the soil and open up the soil
profile in the previous picture does
this Udine and sorghum
those roots normally go down that deeper
is that only because they were grown in
look at someone right the cylinder helps
no question but the Soudan grass
actually does have a pretty strong
imperative to grow downward it varies a
lot they have roots have a lot of cues
of gravity light water nutrients there's
a lot of things telling them where it's
worth putting more roots and they
prioritize and some things just
naturally prioritize gravity more and
the radish is one that puts that pretty
high up on the list physical restriction
is when they like to turn sideways if
they hit something hard and Thomas is
that daikon harvest harvest all
commercially well yeah can you eat them
they're perfectly fine to eat
I've eaten there's no problem there now
the seed companies that sell vegetable
seed will sell you daikon radish seed at
one hundred and seventy-five dollars a
pound and the cover crop companies will
tell you tillage radish seed at three
dollars of thousands so I'll let you
guess what the what the vegetable
companies are doing so they are they're
not quite the quality that will let you
compete in the high-end daikon radish
farmers market restaurant sales art but
it's a perfectly good daikon radish so
look where I'm left on this tillage
question is how can cover crops aid
reduced tillage and this is a picture of
one example where this is is after
harvest in the fall planting rye in the
between crop row spaces and planting
radish in the crop row spaces the Rye is
going to survive the winter and provide
a good cover the radish is going to grow
open up the rooting zone below the
radish and then it's going to die and it
will completely decomposed by springtime
so you'll have a seed zone all
reformed it may not require any tillage
at all or it may require very very
gentle tillage in the spring the Rye can
stay there until you're ready for it to
be done and then you can terminate it
with an herbicide and one of the
technologies that we have now that I'm
having a lot of fun with is the GPS
steering so that you can plant this with
your GPS and I've seen 100 acre fields
planted absolutely dead straight that's
theory but then the following year you
can come in and plant your crop exactly
where the radishes were not half an inch
over exactly where they were and even if
the Rye was killed early and is mostly
decomposed by the time they're coming
out the plant you still hit it perfectly
and you can come back to that spot the
following year in the year after that
and after that are you asking that yes
so then there was the whole rotation
question I mean it's so the question was
whether which crucifer you have to worry
about carrying over flea beetles for the
subsequent crop if you're going strong
and cold crop it yes absolutely that's a
problem so you have to choose rotation
crops appropriately so that they are
compatible in the rotation sequence
further complicating your vegetable
rotations so that is that's a specific
challenge you have a lot of constraints
that come in but I see this sort of
thing as having lots of promise for
vegetables and I did some trials this
year where we took these highly
compacted fields and we did the deep
zone tillage that honours program has
been working quite a bit on for
vegetables and planted beans which are
some of the wimpiest vegetables out
there and they did great first year out
so the idea would be to have to disco
cold turkey on this middle zone and to
stop filling it and do deep zone tiller
in that part as long as it needs it but
also use the cover crop so that that
tillage is more effective or can be
more gently so that is very much the
direction I see us going on soil health
and cover crops and vegetables
intimately tied in with the reduced
tillage so I'm going to switch over now
to some questions that growers have to
get adoption so the first question is
where can i buy the seed but the other
major question is when should I plant it
and so the time to match the cover crop
to the planting date you need to get a
fast start you need to have it during a
part of the season where it produces
enough biomass and you also need to have
it during a part of a season so it will
not produce seed because cover crops
need to think wonderful weeds and so we
don't want those so having ones that die
or can be killed before they make seeds
is important because their day length
and temperature sensitive that can be
fairly predictable and showing this is
the slide is in every grower talk I give
because if you know how to farm do you
know how to get a fast start you know
how to get no gaps you know how to kill
things so if you want to be successful
with cover crops make sure you do those
things and then you're likely to do well
and so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the fast start as the main part
we're getting to here so this is what a
fast start looks like with buckwheat
that's cover crop I'm gonna talk quest
in this experiment so for days you may
see it looks a little yellow so the
cotyledons are up on the fourth day
after planting at three weeks
essentially full cover at five weeks
time to kill you see the difference in
color between three weeks and five weeks
that color change is dramatic and it's
the signal to kill buck if you're going
cover cropping unmistakeable but so that
three weeks full cover that's part of
the smothering effect of cover crops
true if weed management is part of your
program
for sure and generally speaking you
don't want reads in your cover crop
anyway that's the seeding rate on
something like this this is 60 to 70
pounds in it there's this 160 pounds
nature but not not very high it's just
nice uniform cheek placement so we
wanted to find out when during our
growing season can you plant buck weeds
and so one of this is the fast start
parameter so we're measuring ground
cover at three weeks somewhat
arbitrarily saying that 70 percent
ground cover at three weeks is good so
that's that's the number we're trying to
hit so I've got the horizontal line
across there and three very different
seasons produce some different curves
but in short having it so in the fall
it's in the in May it's really too cool
and it grows slowly it likes a little
bit warmer and so the weeds during
during May plantings the weeds will the
early season weeds will beat the
buckwheat pretty consistently but if you
get into June and July and early August
it's looking good for a fast start so
that's pretty long and then the other
one is getting enough biomass and so
here we're looking at the biomass at 42
days so that's when we typically kill it
and June and July still look pretty good
but once you get into August there's a
an abrupt drop and basically that's
because it gets cold in September and it
stops growing in September so even
though I came out of the ground like a
rocket because it was warm and white in
early July it slams on the brakes once
you get into seven September so the
August plant things don't actually do
well and so the thing is if you're
you're busy you're this is crazy time of
year for vegetable growers and you're
harvesting and the end of July feels
just like the beginning of August
but the
difference between putting your
buckwheat in here and put in your bucket
in there is the difference between
success and failure it's really
important to hit the date right so we
had a lot of data like that and we
developed a degree day model to figure
out when the planting date is that you
can get both the fastest start and
enough biomass and through the climate
centers we worked up a map for actually
covering the Midwest as well for the
last effective planting date of
buckwheat the thing that struck me about
this map is that if you look in the
Midwest you can see that the date zones
the borders between the date zones
pretty much follow the interstates so
you can say oh it's this state if you're
north of Interstate 70 but if you're
trying to talk about New York it's a
completely modeled it's really hard so
you need some sort of a local map or
something to tell you for a particular
farm what are you going for the other
thing that shows up pretty clearly is
that down here at Beltsville where a lot
of cover crop work gets done they're
dealing with a completely different
situation very very different timing
region so I also have worked a lot on
the crucifer cover crops which we never
use in broccoli production as sweet
needles and other reasons but they're
they're popular for a couple of reasons
one is that they're cheap to use seeds
cost the dollar two three or four
dollars use five or ten pounds per acre
so the seed cost ends up being
relatively low and this the amount of
stuff you have to bring out there is
fairly low with the small seeds so Bry
you're planting maybe 150 200 pounds an
acre
or in the similar range so you can
imagine if you have a 50 acre field this
is a lot of stuff you're hauling out and
driving around the field with but the
crucifer is it's a lot less much easier
and for the vegetable systems remember I
said that you're harvesting when the
nitrogen levels are still really high
both in the soil in the crop residue
these are great scavengers of nitrogen
and so they will they're a good tool for
soaking up that excess nitrogen carrying
it over to the next year so it's not
lost and so we did some similar work
with mustard so this is with an Brainard
in at Michigan State here
it's the Kellogg Biological Station and
the free vill farm here so both sites
had certified organic land that we could
work on an organic funded project and
weed control in the fall is especially
interesting through organic growers and
here again you can see that abrupt drop
from getting good biomass to getting
very little again very very abrupt
window closing and so there we developed
a degree day model and so the buckwheat
model looks very similar to this and
what you can see in this model is that
there's a lot of degree days when it's
nothing nothing nothing nothing
and then fairly quickly it comes up and
makes however big it's going to be and
they collect more degree days in
Michigan also that was something you
notice consistently that there they have
would usually catch a little more season
but in most locations that rise happened
about the same place so we could do a
model for that also so we have basically
the same kind of map but now developed
for mustard and that's thankfully a
little bit simpler here in New York so
making statements about when to plant
though the mustard cover
and we've tested a bunch of different
crucifer and they're all the same from
the super process that have radish to
the really really cold hardy winter
canola and even though they're winter
hardiness varies the degree day
requirement for growth in the fall is
exactly the same on all of them so the
last planting date applies to all the
crucifer it's not just mustard so we
went another step along for helping the
growers so this is with video Neal and
Bryan Belcher with Cornell climate smart
farming which you can find a bunch of
tools at climate smart farming park
they're doing really nifty stuff and so
this is one of a set of tools that they
have that's tied in with the cover crop
decision tools that I've put online and
if you pick your location but not
everybody gets it again you can put your
farm your field if it's a big farm you
can put different fields some people are
at different elevations and so we've got
this for mustard Ryan buckwheat and it
says what's the probability of success
in here I define what success is and it
will show you the curve of your odds of
success and if you mouse along there so
I have the mouse on August 31st here it
tells you you have a 27% chance of
success if yours you can see the history
since 1978 how many years there were
enough growing degree days by that
planting date
so some people like to gamble more than
others so that gives you the exact now
how risky is it and this is the scary
part to me
the dark line here is the 15 year
average and the gray line is the 30 year
average so it counts another 15 years
back in history so that difference
represents how much warmer the last 15
years have been than the previous 15
that's a big difference and it shows up
on all of them through
the Northeast's all the locations we've
tried to chose up to different extents
and all of the cover crops that have
different degree day models shows up so
anyway we're providing growers with
tools like this and even though they're
targeted pretty narrowly to New York
vegetable growers it's not a huge group
in the audience it gets used fifty to a
hundred times a day year round so
there's the adoption is quite high so
that's been pretty rewarding so let's
show a little bit about weed suppression
which is another management goal not
soil health in the fast start so you
want the cover crop buckwheat here to
come up faster than the weeds and in
this picture it didn't if I saw this I'd
say whoops let's try that again so here
is a trial we did with buckwheat with
the question how much tillage do you
actually need in order to get a
buckwheat cover crop established
effectively enough to suppress the weeds
for the rest of the growing season so
this is after a pea harvest so they come
off fairly early in the season and in
this the green is the buckwheat cover
crop orange are the weeds that come up
in the cover crop and yellow is the weed
pressure so that's how much weeds were
there if we didn't have a cover crop
there and with no-till you can see that
the weeds grow just as happily as they
would have otherwise and the buckwheat
doesn't really grow very well because it
has such a fine root system that just
straight no-till it goes into ground
that's too hard
and there are germinated weeds present
already but disking enough to just kill
the weeds and provide a little bit of a
seed bed now you get pretty good
buckwheat growth and you get a pretty
good suppression of the weeds so that's
planted immediately after tillage so the
the rule of thumb is wait a couple of
weeks so we're violating that rule
clearly we did a chisel treatment also
in case there was going to be puddling
but that turned out not to happen so
it's essentially the same treatment
there and essentially the same result
and then when we waited a week so the
buckwheat actually liked that and we did
get great weed suppression then but we
did it a couple of other years and it we
started to see some weed germination if
you wait the two weeks this is actually
weeds that have now germinated by the
time you plant so you're not getting a
fast start relative to the weeds and
having that much weed biomass is
actually worrisome because it's in your
cover crop and it could be going to seed
later so that's even though it's not a
real big bar it's it's a problem so we
don't want that so what we're saying is
you can after you've harvested a
vegetable you need enough tillage to
kill weeds get a seed bed but that's it
no more and don't wait plant the cover
crop right away tried it later in the
fall with the mustard system and here
the the line is how big the cover crop
was the blue bar is the weed pressure
how many weeds were there this is weed
biomass and the red ones are how much it
is with mustard so if you see a big
difference between the blue bar and the
red bar that means the mustard was
working and so early in the season when
the mustards fade you're getting some
weeds freshened but also some
significant weed growth in the mustard
so this is Michigan this is New York but
one thing we're finding is when we go
late into the season we know we're not
getting great weed suppression but we're
getting a lot of weed suppression even
when the mustard is really small in the
fall so there's some good competition
happening right away and when the
mustard comes out of the ground and is
competing with those green seedlings and
it's not so much and those about the
growth afterwards and then
yes the questions are specific weeds
being suppressed you can easily think
that it's that the cover crop targets
certain weeds and not other weeds and if
we look at just all weed numbers that
come up after you've incorporated the
cover crop we're finding that it's
essentially the same 100% means there's
no difference so we compared mustard and
no mustard but for something like lambs
quarters we're seeing a reduction by
half so great but helpful and then we
tested a haiku casino late mustard
against the low glucosinolate mustard
thinking that this is the bio fumigation
effect in the in the West and other long
season areas they do bio fumigation with
mustards that are high in glucosinolates
so this is to try to assess how big is
the effect of bio few million versus all
the other effects that the cover crop
has and we found no difference like we
found no difference ever my thought is
that by remediation isn't really what
we're doing so you don't have to worry
about that in our region we go to a
couple of other weeds and they like
mustard mustard stimulates their
germination so it could go either way
and a couple of others that we were
worried about had even smaller effect so
we're not seeing super dramatic specific
effects here on the on the weeds that
come up after the cover crop so I'm
gonna dip that one and go to the
take-home messages so that you're
thinking about the cover crop works that
I'm doing how it impinges on your work
so think about using cover crops to
assist your efforts to reduce tillage
that's a good context and if you're
studying the effects of cover crops it's
helpful to look at it in the context of
your
production systems a lot of the things I
talked about here we came up with a
different answer from the place where
that system was originally developed
because our constraints are different
the answers are different so if you're
going to be useful to the audience
locally here you need to test it in the
system with the constraints that we have
understanding the mechanics like the
allele bioaccumulation I just saw showed
on the last slide understanding
something about the mechanics now happen
how does the transition into no-tillage
work what's going on in the soil how are
you getting the higher infiltration
rates for instance and I have to repeat
bass start no gaps kill on time seven
words you got those words you remember
nothing else and then fitting the cover
crops into the production system in as
many places possible to try to achieve
that year-round roots that are going to
keep feeding that soil biota that's so
interesting you will all be learning
more about in a few years to come
and in doing this work I've collaborated
with a bunch of people so there's a ton
or I think it comes to about a ton and a
half of collaborators that have been
particularly involved in right so the
question is filling on time so garlic is
pulled out fairly early in the season so
you have time to plant buckwheat the
buckwheat grows up nicely it's very
different root system and disease
profile
from the garlic it's presses the weeds
for the rest of the summer but a lot
more than 42 days so okay it's flowering
it's making seeds so didn't it killed on
time the way I described it but what
Donna also said we don't really have a
problem with weeds presumably buckwheat
being in that so it is making seeds but
the rest of your management is taking
care of the weeds seedlings that result
it cultivates really easily so some
people don't worry about them and so in
your case killing on time is whenever
the frost gets them and then you have a
no tillage system and in the springtime
you have good good conditions so yes so
with buckwheat you probably do lose
nitrogen over the season because it will
decompose a lot during the winter so as
long as it remains protein into the
spring it's likely to stay in the system
but if it decomposes to the point where
you have nitrates or even even amino
acids to some extent the nitrate will be
nitrifying time you have saturated soil
which you will have guaranteed some time
before planting and and it also leach
out if there's if there's leaching going
on so there the the amino acids will
also leach out organic matter so if it's
trying to keep it from decomposing too
much before spring time is the goal and
buckwheat is going to so how long does
it take to get the seed from buckwheat
so the the 42 day thing is actually very
closely related to that because you
start getting viable embryos very soon
after that and a lot of the times if you
kill buckwheat by mowing there's little
branches that are left with the seed
heads and they'll actually sit there and
mature and so you can produce quite a
lot of seeds from those while they're
decomposing well while the rest of the
plant is decomposing the cedar maturing
so even though it would typically be 70
days until you've harvested commercial
seed selling it at even 50 days you're
likely to get seeds out of that one it's
pretty touching this idea of like how
spatially distributed those actually
occur like are we talking cuz they're
generally uniform compaction actually
break it up is it like are you sort of
like just gonna punching a hole through
it yeah yeah so the structure of the
compaction well we have a couple of
compaction tools that we use a lot so
one is the moldboard plow so as it goes
along it's actually lifting the soil
it's a big heave so the counteracting
force is pushing against the soil
downward with the ploughshare and so
that is where the plow pan comes from
and if it's at all moist down there and
here it's usually moist down there that
creates a pretty uniform compaction plow
pan that will be uniform across the
field it'll be thicker where the soil is
wetter so if there are wetter spots in
the field which is typical of our fields
they'll be worse our other tool is the
disc that that's a much shallower level
but it scours as it goes across so it
can make this nice glossy area just just
below the seed couple of inches down so
he come down
so for having the cover crops grow
through its really the lower one the
plow pan I think you're thinking about
and they're yes they would be pushing
sideways so it's being compacted
vertically so ultimately you would want
to be moving the soil up and having the
air spaces take up that space and that's
really the only direction you can push
so eventually it will get there but as
the roots go through yet they're pushing
radially around the know they're
perforating the compaction is how I
think about it that's right yes so this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu